il y a quatre ans michel forget s'est
fait amputer la jambe gauche à la suite
d'un accident de moto elles marchent
aujourd'hui avec fierté
ça m'émeut parce que je pensais pas
retrouver si près du naturel
jusqu'à tout récemment elle portait une
prothèse à en bois tueur rigide mais
l'appareil entraîner chez elle des maux
de dos c'était mon autonomie vu que
juive et soeurs donc je la portais du
matin au soir
belz a décollé et là je faisais
l'irritation les brûlures et tout seul
et il fallait que je prenne du repos
donc jeté quelques jours enfermée chez
moi fauteuil roulant voilà le site et
aux intégrations une nouvelle
intervention chirurgicale a changé sa
vie depuis près d'un mois et demi et la
tâche directement sa prothèse en tiges
métalliques insérés dans l'os du moignon
c'est le chirurgien orthopédiste robert
turcotte qui l'a opéré une intervention
d'environ deux heures
couverte pour une première fois par la
régie de l'assurance maladie du québec
là c'est en fait comme est inquiet quand
on a gravi l'origine pour pouvoir
rentrer sous suppression si vous voulez
une tige de métal qu'on va la peau le
stéréo intégration coûte environ 60
milles dollars dans le réseau privé
mais au cours des trois prochaines
années environ 150 patients pourront en
bénéficier dans le système public grâce
à un financement du ministère de la
santé d'un million et demi de dollars
par année
la majorité des amputations viennent des
complications du diabète en amérique du
nord et cette procédure ne s'adresse pas
eu ça s'adresse vraiment aux gens comme
des ampliations suite à des traumas wade
cancer quatre mois de réadaptation sont
nécessaires pour réapprendre à marcher
des infections sont possibles 95% des
gens gardent leurs plages dans les cinq
premières familles
non seulement 5% d'ici je m'en veux dire
l'étendue michel forget elles rêvent
déjà de prendre une marche avec son
chien dans un sentier ici marié fouzi
non radio canada montréal